okay let's jump into a few other things
here
uh sean hannity the fox news host and
propagandist
friend of trump he's refusing to say
whether he has been vaccinated against
covid19 and i have some thoughts as to
why he's doing this
so we're going to listen to this this is
audio from sean hannity's radio program
i think that to some degree hannity is
in a weird place now where he's kind of
depressed that the guy he cozied up to
for four years
lost and is out of power and
increasingly people are no longer paying
attention to hannity either so i think
there's there's a bunch of things
going on but let's jump in here listen
to sean hannity and talk about why he's
saying
everybody knows about masks right
everyone knows about
social distancing everybody knows the
vaccines available
pretty much now to anyone if you're over
16.
everybody knows what level of risk
they want to take look my attitude is
you know do your studying know the signs
to the best that we can even say we have
science involved in any of this
so so you know that's kind of that aside
where
they love to throw in the idea that
because our understanding of certain
aspects of the virus have changed over
the last 14 months
can we ever really trust anything that's
coming from the scientific community
and this is part of this is part of the
virtue of science
that science has science is a process
that is self-correcting
where there are rewards for correcting
information that previously we
misunderstood
um and and in fact that should make us
trust more in the process okay let's
continue
because they've gotten so much wrong the
great dr fauci's been wrong so often
okay so maybe i should have played that
first before mentioning but again
the fact that fauci early said one thing
about masks
but then for the last 12 months has been
saying the same thing
that's not a reason to discount what the
medical science community tells us
and the only thing i would ask everyone
is to be considerate
of other people especially older people
those with compromised immune systems
comorbidities
yeah grandma grandpa mom and dad and and
if by that he means
even if you are not at high risk get
vaccinated to protect them
then i'm with him i'm not sure if that's
what he means so that if
you know at this point i would assume
that they're probably vaccinated
at least they have the opportunity to
get it if they didn't if they
that's another thing why do you have to
answer the question well have you gotten
your vaccine yet which vaccine did you
get
how about it's none of your business how
about well what do you well i mean
you don't people it's called making
conversation it's also
i mean listen right now if my friends
want to gather
indoors i ask if they're vaccinated and
i say
we're only doing indoor stuff with
vaccinated people right now
other than various you know unvaccinated
but work from home
because i'm vaccinated okay it seems
like a responsible question to be asking
you can decline to answer
you mean you're not going to get
vaccinated how about that's a choice
between an individual and a doctor
i'm very pro-science i'm not
anti-vaccine but i'm also
medical i also am a libertarian believer
in medical privacy
it's unbelievable everyone wants to know
medical privacy applies
to practitioners and it applies to
uh records and uh it's not about
nobody can ask i mean essentially
you know he he's almost saying you
shouldn't even be be allowed to say how
have you been doing lately this is not
what medical privacy means
it's like everyone now i'll tell you i
probably would have told people my
decision
until everyone started demanding that i
tell them what my decision is right well
my advice to everybody yeah is research
long and hard on on
everything you can get your hands on and
you can
read the medical literature then i would
look at your special and unique
medical conditions see this this is
really stupid
because first of all it's not really
that difficult to figure it out secondly
looking at your specific situation is
again the kind of joe rogan thing from
earlier of if you're not at risk maybe
you don't get vaccinated and
if you read everything that's out there
as he suggests
a lot of what's out there is
anti-vaccine trash
and that's what a lot of his viewers are
finding on their facebook accounts
your health uh and talk to the doctor
doctors that that take care of you or
again sure ask your doctor
most people don't need to have a
conversation with their doctor about
whether they should get vaccinated
doctor doctors that you respect in life
and make an informed decision
and that is that that's got to be an
individual decision
and there are there people that have had
reaction to the vaccines
yup should you read about that too yes
you should read it all yeah i think it's
good to understand the level of risk
with with getting vaccinated which is
extraordinarily low
and in all cases lower than the risk of
getting the virus but that's fair
you should know that you know one in 1.2
million of the people that got the jnj
women age 18 to 48 had a blood clot um
maybe if you're in that group you opt
for a different vaccine if that's a
degree of risk that concerns you that
that's i agree with that
no i'm not how do i how can i possibly
weigh in on whether everybody needs to
be vaccinated
i don't know people's individual medical
conditions that is not my decision
that's your decision you have the right
to make
your own decision you can take whatever
level of risk
you might want to take i just ask gently
think of other people
and especially the those that would be
more susceptible for the worst outcome
in all of this
so some of what he's saying is okay but
then also
you know when his refusal to say i would
have told people my vaccination status
until everybody started asking that to
me
sounds like a cop-out where sean hannity
was vaccinated
he doesn't want to say it because saying
it will anger the anti-vaxx people in
his audience
much more than not saying anything will
anger the vaccinated people in his
audience it just feels like a
calculation to me
and interestingly this isn't that
dissimilar from what donald trump did in
the sense of trump
was vaccinated at the white house in
january
he didn't mention it he said nothing and
then months later went out of office he
said oh yeah i did receive it or it was
rev it was
announced by his office that he received
it at the white house it it strikes me
as a calculation more than it is about
so-called medical privacy
but really strange stuff happening over
on the hannity program and bottom line
i think hannity's kind of depressed that
his guy is no longer in office and
people are paying a lot less attention
to him than they used to be he's getting
no more rides on marine one
uh but make of it what you will